[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
la muerte es parte de la vida sin
embargo es muy poco aceptada en nuestra
sociedad occidental inclusive por
personas muy religiosas y espirituales
recuerdo mis primeras pérdidas en la
infancia pequeñas para algunos pero
inmensas y profundas para mí
mi canario mi tortuga y como mi mamá me
enseñaba a enterrar los consagrados
rituales envueltos en sábanas viejas con
una maceta destinada a cada uno cuando
la angustia sobre venid a mirar esos
lugares me daba paz
a mis 13 años si fue un momento para mí
terrible porque fue mi primera gran
pérdida falleció mi abuelo paterno y en
medio de la tristeza recuerdo que grite
porque no le dije lo mucho que lo quería
y ahí aprendí a comunicar en vida
ya en mi adolescencia falleció una amiga
de la escuela ella era hermosa alegre
inteligente y ahí entendí que no hay don
ni aún la juventud que te proteja de
llegar al fin
también aprendí que todo sigue el día y
la noche se sucede en el uno al otro
igual que antes nadie es indispensable
dicen pero todos somos únicos
por eso el momento para dar y para
recibir es en vida en vida
ya en mi vida profesional siendo médica
residente aprendí a acompañar a mis
pacientes y a sus familias
en esos duros momentos entonces las
palabras de un viejo maestro el doctor
kubel um venían a mí
antes que médico se es persona
ante todo dignidad revisar sin pudor
respetando el pudor clínico viene
declinó cama el que está junto a la cama
de su paciente y esas enseñanzas tan
congruentes las de mi maestro con las de
mi madre me acompañaron me acompañan y
me acompañarán a lo largo de toda mi
vida
porque mi misión es ayudar donde sea
como sea por eso busco conocer a mi
paciente como si fuera de su familia
conocer sus gustos sus preferencias sus
necesidades y decirle la verdad sin
crueldad por eso cuando vienen al
consultorio o entró a la habitación
tengo un plan a un plan b y hasta un
plan z para adaptarlo a las necesidades
de cada uno y delante del paciente y de
su familia yo me muestro tranquila
aunque por dentro sienta la culpa de no
poder prolongar más tiempo su vida
entonces en ese momento se encuadró y me
digo que yo soy su herramienta para
llevarlo de la mano hasta el portal
y ese es un difícil momento porque
tenemos que soltarlos porque ellos solos
pueden cruzar ese umbral
y entonces viene el dolor porque a veces
nos acompañan por muchos años de
nuestras vidas pasan a ser parte de
nuestra cotidianeidad profesional y
hasta personal así pasó con anna la
conocí cuando yo era médica residente de
segundo año teníamos casi la misma edad
éramos las dos muy jóvenes a ella la
trajo un linfoma al hospital and
aparecía muy temerosa muy frágil y esa
angustia que la embargaba no permitía
que se dejara hacer estudios ni
tratamientos un día las dos descubrimos
qué tomadas de la mano ella permitía que
se le hicieran los estudios y los
tratamientos y anna se empezó a curar y
mientras sano se curaba yo me casaba
tenía hijos y siempre estaba en ella y
su familia junto a mí en mis buenas y en
mi no tan buenas
anna a su vez nos demostró que no era lo
frágil que parecía
o tu emprendimiento se bañó bajo una
catarata es una palabra disfruto pero no
siempre las noticias son tan buenas
después de unos años una nueva
enfermedad sobrevino anna tenía una
leucemia pero a pesar de todo /
complicación y complicación seguía
disfrutando para horror de su madre que
por amor la hubiera querido tener
guardada en una cajita de cristal
el tiempo pasó y un día un domingo
estábamos de recorrida y entró al
hospital una señora muy agitada sentada
en una camilla tenía la cara y las manos
violetas detrás de esa señora vio a la
familia de ana
era anna no lo había reconocido su
cuerpo me marcaba que otra etapa había
llegado entonces una vez más le tomé la
mano y la compañía está terapia
intensiva allí los médicos tenían que
sedarla tenían que asistir la
respiratoria mente y entonces tuve que
soltar su mano por primera vez en 13
años me sentí muy culpable y muy triste
también pero después me di cuenta que ya
no era mi medicina lo que ana necesitaba
ella necesitaba mi lealtad y el amor que
nos habíamos prodigado toda esa vida de
13 años y así es como la compañía de la
mano hasta el portal
junto a anahí a otros pacientes aprendí
siempre a hablar a solas con mis
pacientes a preguntarles sus gustos sus
necesidades sus preferencias y aparte
para conocerlos bien para que ellos
tuvieran la oportunidad de decir me
basta para respetar su principio de
autonomía para evitar el encarnizamiento
terapéutico para que todo sea para
beneficio de nuestros pacientes todo
aquello que hagamos porque algunos no
los conocemos por años como anna los
conocemos por unas horas o por unos
minutos entonces ahí es el amor al
prójimo lo que prima no importa quién
soy no importa quien sos aquí lo único
que importa que estoy para ayudarte te
voy a acariciar te voy a decir palabras
cariñosas al oído te voy a dar confort
te voy a mantener digno acomodar tu
almohada tu sábana como si fuera tú
voy a armar un equipo de almas
bondadosas para acompañarte con nuestra
energía médicos enfermeros kinesiólogos
laicos religiosos y también voy a
acompañar a tu familia a secar sus
lágrimas a responder todas sus preguntas
y sus dudas y así fue con simón simón
pasó un domingo de terapia intensiva
para morir junto a su familia
yo aprendí desde el principio en mi vida
médica que para saber sobre un paciente
primero tenía que revisarlo yo y
escucharlo yo entonces entré a la
habitación y si bueno había tenido un
grave accidente cerebrovascular no podía
mover ni los brazos ni las piernas pero
tampoco podía hablar solo nos podíamos
comunicar con la intensidad de su mirada
y cuando él me miró parecía que me
estaba diciendo y ahora qué vas a hacer
conmigo y los ojos son las ventanas del
alma salí de la habitación y le dije a
la familia que para mí no era el momento
ellos entonces me miraron consternados
porque esperaban otro tipo de noticia
pero sin embargo aunque no me conocían
respetaron mi decisión médica lo que al
principio parecía la prolongación de un
sufrimiento se convirtió en una
oportunidad de dos meses y medio ellos
lo acariciaban lo mimaban le traían
música fotos y hasta pudieron darle
noticias
que de otro modo nunca hubiera recibido
y que lo hicieron derramar lágrimas de
emoción un día me regalaron un cid y de
música folklórica cantado por simon
entonces había una copla donde simón
decía el día que me muera quiero que me
entierren mirando al sur que me del
viento en la cara
e increíble era la voz de simón que
venía del pasado a nuestro presente como
una medida anticipada él era su voz era
su voz ahora es que él no podía
hablarnos y él nos daba sus medidas
anticipadas
simón fue haciendo complicaciones y un
día sentí que con su mirada me decía
basta
consulte esa sensación con el resto del
equipo y todos estábamos de acuerdo era
el momento de las medidas proporcionadas
entonces fuimos acompañando a simón en
ese proceso hasta que su cuerpo se
despidió de nosotros pero su folclórica
alma quedó en cada uno de aquellos que
lo conocimos y mientras en el otro ala
del hospital al mismo tiempo que simón
estaba allí cell giselle era hermosa
joven inteligente hacía cuatro años que
transitaba un cáncer de colon pero ya
estaba más allá de toda terapéutica
oncológica específica venía al hospital
para recibir morfina cuando tenía
intensos dolores
ella era arquetípica mente una guerrera
ella venía le pasábamos la morfina y
prácticamente se gestionaba el alta
entonces se iba a la montaña con un
chamán a andar en avioneta con su
hermano
o quizás se iba en lancha por el tigre o
a trabajar
en una de esas tantas internaciones por
dolor recuerdo que si se le estaba
comiendo en alfajorcitos de maicena
degustándolo porque ella su tubo
digestivo no podía tolerarlo y me dijo
silvia hasta acá no puedo más le pedía
entonces que lo reflexionar a lo
reflexionó unos días y un día yo iría al
hospital y había muchos jóvenes y toda
su familia todos con cartas en las manos
que les había escrito giselle eran
cartas donde les expresaba todo su amor
y donde les hacía pedidos de cuidado
para que cada uno de ellos se cuidaran
había llegado el momento de pasar a una
nueva etapa y no era que ya no era una
guerrera no era una rendición era que
las flechas de su carcaj se habían
acabado
empezamos a acompañarla con la analgesia
con la sedación progresivamente hasta
que un día su cuerpo se despidió también
pero ella sin embargo dejó grabada su
alma con una flecha en cada uno de
nuestros corazones
después de todo esto como verán no
existe una única manera de acompañar a
nuestros murientes de la mano hasta el
portal existen tantas maneras como
personas hay como médicos ahí también
porque cada uno es el 100% para sí mismo
y para los que lo rodean sin embargo hay
algo que siempre tiene que primar y va
más allá de los libros es el amor es el
respeto es la dignidad es el tiempo
propio por eso a mi paciente le digo que
siempre voy a estar acá para ayudarte
siempre voy a estar ayudándote a
reflexionar a que no te abandones a la
desesperación siempre hay una
posibilidad para disfrutar siempre hay
una oportunidad de ver al sol de salir
al parque
viajar de perdonar de pedir perdón
siempre y aunque te hayas ido lejos yo
voy a estar aquí esperándote porque mi
voz mi mano y mi mirada irán contigo y
cuando vuelvas y te tenga que acompañar
de mi mano hasta el portal quédate
tranquilo quédate tranquila siempre
estaré junto a tu familia para ayudarte
para recordarlos y recordar lo que vos
les diste y lo que ellos les dieron
después de lo vivido yo sé que no tengo
miedo a la muerte porque es parte de un
camino y tiene sentido pero sin embargo
los invito a cada uno de ustedes y me
invitó a mi agradecer cada día cuando
abrimos nuestros ojos y que estamos
vivos que pese a las dificultades y a
las limitaciones que podamos tener
tenemos la gran oportunidad de disfrutar
de la vida de disfrutar del día y cuando
el día haya terminado al acostarnos que
al cerrar nuestros ojos agradecer por lo
vivido porque seguro seguro hay algo
algo positivo que ha pasado más allá de
todo algo por lo que valió la pena
ver lo vivido para que ese día cuando la
muerte toque la puerta a cada uno de
nosotros nos podamos ir en paz nos
podamos ir tranquilos de su mano hasta
el portal
[Aplausos]